okay
dozens of you have asked me to address
this issue and i'm ready to address it
today i've been waiting for the story to
develop a little bit
some of you might remember this guy
named jessie lee peterson
jesse lee peterson is sort of a
prominent
uh black conservative he's a christian
pastor he has a men's counseling center
in los angeles which i've been to when i
was on jesse's program a couple of years
ago his studio and his radio show all go
out of the same
building i believe it's called the bond
in los angeles and um it turns out it
appears that the very openly homophobic
anti-gay christian pastor jesse lee
peterson is gay
and i'm going to talk about my
experience with him which included him
being pretty handsy with me to be
perfectly honest i wasn't sexually
harassed i didn't feel intimidated or
anything but at the time i just wrote it
off to this he's this guy's just a
character those beat up he's just pansy
uh but i'm gonna get back to that okay
so here's the story
um
the daily beast now reporting
allegations of manosphere pastors gay
past royal macho men
jesse lee peterson has emerged as one of
the wright's most vocal anti-gay figures
but his one-time friends now allege that
the pastor has had many same-sex
relationships there are so i'm not going
to give you every claim
but there are so many stories now of
people saying
i i was involved in uh in sexual like
men saying i was involved in sexual
activity with jesse lee peterson he um
comes on to people aggressively in many
cases etc two of uh
two of peter's oh hold on let me go back
two of peterson's former male associates
came out in june with on the record
interviews saying they engaged in sexual
activities with them other men say he
propositioned them these allegations
about the pastor who is publicly
staunchly heterosexual have ripped like
an earthquake through the manosphere
prompting some peterson allies to
abandon him and prompting one manosphere
conference to ban him altogether
the daily beast was not able to
substantiate the allegations peterson's
ministry
a brotherhood organization known as bond
did not respond to multiple requests for
comment okay so what's my view on this
i don't care about his uh sexuality per
se i i really could not care less at
this point i i just don't care about
people's sexual orientation it's boring
to me it i just don't care now
jessie lee peterson is definitely an odd
guy
he
is um seemingly obsessed with talking
despite being a black man talking about
how great white people are and how
terrible black people are and he's also
obsessed with talking about how terrible
and sinful and horrible it is to be gay
and he supposedly counsels young men out
of being gay or at least that's what he
claims to do
and it seems as though he is also gay
himself okay
um
what i can tell you is that
the vibe at his counseling office was
really really weird so let me tell you
what i personally observed
was he handsy at his office he was
um he kept you know when we took
pictures
he was sort of like weirdly hugging me
arm around me in a way that's like it's
not
it doesn't raise any red flag
i didn't think he was coming on to me i
didn't feel intimidated or whatever
there were people around
but it was just like it was the first
time i was meeting him and he was a
little bit handsy and i didn't really
think anything of it now in this context
maybe that was something sort of
different he was kind of like whispering
into my ear like not sweet nothings it
was actually about trump he was like and
i've said this before like you're you're
gonna vote for trump aren't you david
you're gonna vote for trump and i quite
literally thought absolutely nothing of
it like nothing at all like what people
are describing
the atmosphere at his office with young
men kind of hanging around
the fact that he counsels young men with
christian counseling i did find it all
weird but not because i thought it was a
way for him to proposition dudes because
it just seemed like this is the last guy
who should be counseling young men and
of course he takes advantage of this
entire thing where as many of you know
to say one is a therapist you actually
need a license you either need to be a
psychologist or
a licensed social worker licensed
independent social worker psychiatrist
licensed mental health counselor he was
none of these things the term counselor
or coach can be used by anybody and he
claimed to be a counselor and of course
he's just a pastor he doesn't actually
have any therapy credentials and that
was the biggest red flag and there were
all these young young men hanging around
and it was odd so is it a shock i mean
not really in the sense that we've seen
now dozens of the most openly
and notably homophobic
christian figures actually be gay
themselves in that sense it's not really
a shock it's only sort of surprising
because this is the only one that i
personally know and who's you know i
went i was with him at his office and
all of these different things so
that's really all i have to say about it
it's not
i mean you know it's it's not
when people started emailing me saying
david it turns out jesse lee peterson is
gay okay i mean that's my concern is
more about
what are the
the lives that he has potentially ruined
now one other thing there was this
interesting moment
jesse lee peterson is all about alpha
the alpha male and he says if you're on
the left you're beta he's called me a
beta male and we had an interview
where i asked him are you like are you
in a relationship are you
um are you sexually active or whatever
and he said that he's off sex
and he's off sex because
out of wedlock i think was the term he
used you know it's inappropriate or
whatever but he seemed visibly
uncomfortable with the line of
questioning and again is it all related
to this entire
hidden homosexuality thing that's going
on maybe i don't know you know in
retrospect hindsight starts to become
clearer and clearer but i don't really
know that any one of these things is
sort of like a big oh it should have
been obvious that he was one of these
homophobic gay guys i i i can't i really
can't say that i can only speak to my
personal experience and that's what it
is very um
i mean it's a sad story
it's not sad that he's gay
it's sad that he's gay and homophobic
that's always sad when people can't just
be who they are and also
that
i have a very strange feeling about the
entire counseling of of young men
quite frankly we're talking about boys
in many cases
uh that he was doing and who knows what
else we may learn about this in the
future that's about it
one of our sponsors is emmy
hands down some of the best ramen
noodles i've had just like any instant
ramen you pop emmy into the microwave or
on the stovetop for a few minutes and
it's ready to go but what makes imme
different is that it is packed with 21
grams of protein lower in sodium 100
plant-based with 18 grams of fiber for
digestive health and it tastes
excellent
so many of the other ramens are bland
simple artificial imi uses high quality
ingredients and recipes you get a zing
of flavor i've never had with any
instant ramen imi comes in amazing
flavors like spicy beef tom yum shrimp
and black garlic chicken if you try me
and don't love it
you get your money back you'll get five
dollars off when you go to emmyeats.com
pacman and use the code pacman at
checkout the link is down below